se trata de una ciudad aún lastimada por
la violencia que la sacudió en mayo
durante las protestas varias sinagogas
fueron incendiadas un cementerio
musulmán vandalizado dos hombres
murieron y gallego shuar residente judío
linchado con piedras y musa hash una
árabe asesinado con disparos de
extremistas judíos
y aún líderes del pd
estaba tras ellos al frente y este
colono le disparó en el corazón en el
corazón
en el corazón venga
katia es una vecina judía que conoce
bien a la familia de musa residente
histórica de lot
los unos se implantaron antes de 1948 y
la creación del estado de israel
siempre vivimos con los judíos
normalmente nunca hubo problemas entre
nosotros al contrario trabajamos juntos
nos visitamos durante las fiestas
nuestro problema es con los otros judíos
los extremistas que trajeron los que
señalan como extremistas o colonos son
una minoría judía ultranacionalista
acusada de querer judaizar las ciudades
mixtas durante las protestas algunos
llegaron de otras ciudades
autoproclamándose protectores de los
juzgados es para sacar a los palestinos
de lot no hay seguridad llegan en
cantidad los colonos extremistas que
vinieron a lot tenían un objetivo atacar
a los árabes para sacarlos
los datos de caja yo sabía que algo
podía pasar
pero nunca hubiese pensado en algo como
eso
es muy triste
hay odio racismo de los colonos
es a participar
si la política del alcalde es hacer
venir colonos nunca podrá haber
reconciliación entre árabes y judíos hay
que prepararse para una carnicería
y las islas
hace años que las relaciones inter
comunitarias están envenenadas el 30 por
ciento de los árabes de la ciudad le
reprocha al alcalde que obra solo a
favor de los judíos e impulsa la llegada
de miembros de garín torán y una
comunidad religiosa de la que hace parte
está el que empezó a implantarse en las
ciudades mixtas en los años 90 para
reforzar su religiosidad
es triste y es chocante saber que hay
gente que puede venir así a incendiar su
casa
solo por odio
para el abandono una colonia de
cisjordania hace dos años para
instalarse en este barrio árabe de la
ciudad este no es su apartamento sino el
de una familia de garín objetivo durante
las protestas
las relaciones de vecindad eran pocas
hoy en día parecen imposibles
había ataques con bomba y sonaban las
sirenas debíamos bajar al refugio debajo
del edificio pero lo grabamos nos
dijimos es más seguro quedarse en casa o
tomamos el riesgo a sabiendas de lo que
sucede de ir al refugio con las familias
árabes finalmente decidimos no ir porque
teníamos algo
con el paso de los años el garín torán y
obtuvo permisos para elegir una ciudad
en la ciudad
hoy en día 1200 familias viven juntas su
sueño sionista
mordechai abandonó los ángeles hace 13
años para agrandar la comunidad
originalmente había cinco edificios y
éramos algunos miembros orgullosos de
garín como una semilla judía que
sembramos en lo de ahora si se voltea
verán todos estos nuevos edificios que
fueron construidos estos cinco o seis
últimos años para ser claros esto es una
comunidad judía no hay árabes es una
comunidad judía esto fue construido para
la comunidad judía originalmente los
apartamentos debían ser vendidos
únicamente a judíos religiosos
en la entrada del complejo está este
afiche de un movimiento de extrema
derecha israelí mordechai niega sin
embargo que ello refleja la ideología de
la comunidad cuyo único objetivo sería
mejorar la calidad de vida en los
[Música]
y su vídeo promocional en el ts de hecho
la creación de escuelas guarderías
canchas en su página web reduce la
infiltración masiva de población árabe
problemática y una criminalidad
galopante este sentimiento de
inseguridad es compartido por los
miembros de karim con los cuales pudimos
hablar por deia y está convencido de que
su ideología puede traer de vuelta a la
calma en la ciudad
seguimos trayendo más judíos a la ciudad
agrandamos garín construimos más
edificios reclamamos un mejor sistema
educativo mejores servicios públicos y
por supuesto una mejor policía sólo
queremos buenas personas en la ciudad
incierto y si hay buenos árabes que
quieren instalarse en lo fantástico si
hay buenos árabes que vienen fantasy
mejorarse camps s
el contraste es elocuente cuando
llegamos a barrios árabes
[Música]
según un reciente informe de la ocde set
son de lejos los más pobres y el
desempleo es 10% más elevado
esos jóvenes árabes participaron en las
manifestaciones contra la expulsión de
palestinos en jerusalén este y muchos
fueron detenidos prefieren entonces
hablar de manera anónima los palestinos
están siendo expulsados de su casa y la
justicia israelí ordenó evacuar las
casas para instalar colonos en su lugar
sienten que se está traspasando a su
ciudad el conflicto que desgarra los
territorios ocupados
por ejemplo aquí a los judíos les dan
casas a precios muy bajos con el
contrario nosotros tenemos que obtener
un permiso y si no contamos con ese
permiso de muel en nuestras casas
yo tengo
considerando la situación actual no me
veo viviendo aquí con este racismo ya no
puedo vivir aquí
la juventud árabe está fragmentada pero
en israel como los territorios parece
converger hacia el mismo sentimiento de
injusticia y de rabia por ahora la calma
ha regresado a la luz pero esta semana
de violencia sacudió por mucho tiempo su
frágil equilibrio